[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i'm here with a legend
absolute legend
of uh south florida really the whole
world but
what's going on man how are you mark
everything's great thanks a lot for
having me
all right uh you are one of the owners
of the highest grossing club
per square foot in the world with 11.
which is a club here in miami
you guys started to take bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies as payment
why'd you do that well we did it uh
really because we
pride ourselves to be the forefront
pioneers in all aspects of business
and the momentum for cryptocurrencies
has been incredible especially in the
last
six to eight months then when the
cryptocurrency conference was coming to
miami
it really lit a light bulb in our heads
and we said uh you know what we better
be at the forefront of this because
somebody's gonna do it might as well be
us
and you know we're the most well-known
club in the world and with everybody
coming to town
it was just seemed like a idea that you
had to do
so uh when you announced it i think at
first you were like oh you know it's
just like kind of a
nonsense move they're just announcing it
they're not gonna actually accept it or
people aren't gonna really pay
but people have been paying in bitcoin
right well you know the funny thing is
you don't just say i'm taking crypto and
all of a sudden you start processing it
it took a a a lot of complexities to
figure it out
and our guys that worked for us were
incredible at it and we
figured it out we do trial and error we
tried a few different processing uh
people and before the conference we hit
bingo we
really had a seamless uh a team that
just
processes stuff uh without any errors
you know a lot of other people tried in
miami and every i think we no one's even
accepted it because once people saw us
we were accepting it
everyone in the world tried to accept it
but they were uh
not able to execute on it and we
executed on it to perfection and we took
a lot of bitcoin
it was great it was it was a very smart
move and a very profitable move and a
wise move and
uh everything that comes with it and uh
we were proud to be the first ones
and we're also uh planning on staying
with it and leading the forefront
because we're very big believers
in bitcoin and the cryptocurrencies so i
know that you hopefully this isn't
sharing too much i know that you own
some bitcoin
right you're very interested in the
space uh the club's now accepting it
and uh people have already paid but
they're not just paying like 20 for a
drink right i mean these are people who
are buying tables they're
um taking out cash like they're they're
doing a whole bunch of different things
with it and that's where really
you guys have processed a lot of the
bitcoin transactions yeah people are
asking you know our tables that are a
place right from 5 000 to 50 000 a table
some are
75 100 depending on the night and uh the
big boy has been playing
bitcoin i mean they've been coming and
coming hard
it's very profitable and i'm really glad
because i have to say that uh
you know you said that i owned bitcoin
on a lot of bitcoin because of you and
particularly
you know and you helped me believe in it
and
it's kind of contagious because people
see i believe in it and people see you
believe in it and now
miami everybody's moving down here in
the crypto world so miami's becoming
like the crypto capital of the world
and i'm just really glad to be learning
and meeting people and get involved i
really believe it's the embryonic stages
and i think it's going to be a
significant part of our business going
forward yeah
i i tend to agree uh there's a second
part of uh of what you do so i think
most people
know of 11 gold rush and kind of the
clubs because that's a kind of a
forward-facing big thing
but really your entire business uh
historically has been from real estate
right like you're
you've developed real estate you've
bought real estate maybe walk us through
just kind of your career and how do you
get to this point
well it all began when i was in college
i went to american university i played
division one college basketball
my basketball coach was gary williams
who coached maryland to national title i
think in 2002 or 2003.
and what position did you play by the
card i was uh we had we had a really
good team division one you know we were
one of the top 20 teams in the country
actually
we had a really good team and i had
these aspirations of being a pro
and they were very quickly uh dimmed
when i started playing college i mean i
had a
very good first year and then uh we had
a
teammate of mine russell boo bowers
who's the leading scorer the entire
country
and about midway through the uh
the season uh beau came to practice very
lethargic
and gary williams who was a complete
maniac coach i mean he didn't put up
with anything he said bo
you're very lethargic what's going on he
said coach
these agents i get up in the morning
they're knocking on my door i go to bed
they're knocking my door in the middle
of the night they're not going to my
door i can't get i can't even get rid of
them
i can't sleep it's the next agent that
came on the campus
got arrested i'm literally arrested
and he and he was not out of jail for
like
four to five days so the word got out
don't go near
american university campus when you're
blue bowers you're going to jail
so me the enterprising uh young man i
was i said i want to be his agent
so i started giving my per diem money i
started hanging out with him i started
becoming his best friend
and lo and behold he made me his agent
all right so hold on a second
you're his teammate but you realize that
all these agents all want to be his
agent and because they think he's going
to be highly selected in nba draft all
this stuff
and you're like well why would we let
them be the agent why don't i just be
your agent yes
exactly exactly cyber came as a there's
only one problem as a kid
i could barely like read you know kind i
know what a contract was
so i had a camp counselor for when i was
12 years old i remember he became a
lawyer
so i dialed him up and i said his name
was roy greenman
i said listen roy i got a uh athlete
like i want to sign him you want to be
my partner and he goes who is it i said
russell boo bowers
now blue bauer's a big name back then
this is going back 40 years ago
he said you have boob hours i said yeah
i've got boo bowers you know i
decide them i go say okay let's partner
up
so i signed up we became partners i
started signing other athletes
and all of a sudden i said okay i'm not
going to be a pro i know this and if i
stay in the school any longer back then
there was all kinds of stuff going on
college
learning wasn't one of them so i said i
better get out of here
so i left college after three semesters
i started my sports business all right
and so when you
sign him and then you start going to
other athletes what's your pitch to them
oh my pitch was my pitch of it was uh
you know these guys are gonna be home
with their wives and kids i'll be out
there working for you
like when i was getting out with you
know that's still my pitch today by the
way even though i have a wife and kids
but nobody out works me
i'd say i'm going to outwork them i'm
going to i i said i'm going to find the
best people for you i said
nobody's going to get you a bigger
contract nobody can find more
endorsements
and yeah it's just like a ball of energy
and you know me now how i am you imagine
me
oh they loved it i signed a lot of guys
up so i started signing guys up
and i built a very substantial uh sports
entertainment business
a matter of fact i was the first one to
take a
sports management company public on the
national nasdaq
so how long into the lifetime of the
companies before you take it public
well i started signing guys up uh the
first thing i did was get into
uh signing up guys and i was about 19.
i got a call from the local pal
representative and he said to me
because there's a big article about me
my local paper that's how i signed all
these guys i'm an agent all this stuff
so this guy called me off that article
and says uh he's calling me mr roberts
guys like the head of the pal
the knight to okay he's mr roberts uh
just right about you how do you like to
represent some fighters
i said at that point would represent
like a snail know i'm not doing anything
so i said
yeah that's a great idea what do you
need me to do he says meet me at the gym
you give me an address in plainfield new
jersey goes we have three state
champions
and a couple more national champions
when you you know come manage them i
said okay let me go look at him
so i went down a sweaty gym in
plainfield new jersey there's these
animals working out like peace
so i go which of the three best here he
goes right over here
he says there's national champ national
champ national gym so i'll take all
three
he said okay we brought the trainer over
he was listen
here's the way it works you're going to
put the trainer on a salary you got to
give the guys a little money each week
you got to get them fights and you'll
build them up i don't know anything
about boxing
so it's okay i'll take them so i went
and said okay where do i get the money
for all this
it's a 90 year old kid so i go to my
lawyer partner that was agent i said
he goes well there's a thing called a
limited partnership
i said i need about 60 grand with all
this stuff to take me to like at least a
year and a half before i
started making these guys some money i
guess they said
well you got it from a limited
partnership and i got i don't understand
what you're talking about i said listen
how much money i have to raise he goes
well i say let's do like
six units at 50 000 each
okay okay so i went out and i begged
borrowed i was out i was literally
called every friend i ever met
to talk to her dads or uncles our aunts
everybody
and i raised the money in a liberal
partnership that was my first big race
all right so you did six units at 50k
and now you got you know three hundred
thousand dollars
and what do you do with it i housed the
guys i fed the guys i put the trader on
retainer
uh you know a salary built a little bit
of a gym
and then i went out to try to find a
fight so i remember i called up bob lee
the uh uh well first off
i just called all over the world to get
these guys fight i couldn't get a fight
to save my life for these guys i called
every promoter and there wasn't
in the world i finally got the guy my
one guy albert steele mills
he was a national champ i got him a
fight in hartford connecticut
he he was fighting on a card with this
guy marlon starling who was a big
big troll at the time we drove up to
hartford i brought my partner he brought
his
two up partners the three of us going up
there my first fight
it's a four round fight my guy gets
there he knocks the guy from ring post a
ring post a ring post a ring post
we're going yeah i can't believe we all
have our first victory
it says 15 000 people in the stadium
because marlon strong is a big draw
the decision comes in my guy lost
how the heck did that happen so i
started explaining to me the facts of
life of boxing
because you can't fight a guy in his
hometown you got to knock him out
you know he told me that so on the way
home i say you know what
i'm going to start promoting my own
fights in our own town if that's the way
this game works
so i started promoting fights that are
in plainfield new jersey which is right
by where i grew up
and the first fight i was pulled up the
chairs i thought the posters i was doing
this set don't like the matchmaking i
didn't know what the heck i was doing
and two days before the fight there was
like no sales
and literally no sales i was like
freaking because all the money was gonna
be gone
so i said uh what the heck am i gonna do
i didn't know what to do all of a sudden
sales started picking up and picking up
and picking up the fights sold out 3 000
people
packed arena packed house what happened
was i was in
plain from jersey was a little bit of a
urban area
and the day before the fight two days
before the fight was when the welfare
checks came out
and everybody got the money everybody
started buying tickets i didn't know i
was just lucky to draw
like the real draw and i sold the place
out a very successful shot as the
youngest person ever to promote a
professional
boxing match and hold that distinction
to today
i started promoting more boxing matches
i met emmanuel stewart
who was number one boxing trainer of all
time
then i got involved with tommy hearns
with him and started doing stuff with
tommy
and i started managing other athletes
and then and uh then i signed the 1988
u.s olympic team
i got ray mercer the gold medal champion
i managed him to the heavyweight title
my first heavyweight champion knocked
out tommy morrison in a
brutal knockout i'm just a crazy brutal
knockout
and that then i started uh i
we took that company public uh through
the number one company on wall street at
the time called dh blair
national nasdaq built that company up
that company sold for
uh a lot everybody made a lot of money a
lot of money
that seems to be a recurring theme when
you uh are involved in a business
everyone makes a lot of money
yeah that's the idea that's definitely
the idea and then i
then a couple years later i took another
sports management company public
and we did football basketball nascar
we did a lot of endorsements we had a
big marketing division
and we built that up and then i sold
that and then about
so that was around like first about
coming to june and my account said to me
it was back in like 99.
my account said to me hey you know if
you could move to a state with no state
income tax you could save this much
money
it was a significant amount i said
really yeah i said he said yeah you go
to florida nevada texas
i thought i'm going to south beach
so i came right down to south beach i
bought a place at south beach
and i've been here ever since and i was
going to retire for a year
and what i did i used to go around to
new construction jobs
and give deposits on units this was
miami's just starting to get really
booming with with the high rises
and i bought about maybe 100 condos
and i started making a lot of money just
on because you were just buying the
units and then renting them so no no i
just bought the
i bought to use pre-construction gave a
deposit
then the developers did all the work and
then when they
were built you just flip them i got it
you should resell them i just resold
them it did very well
then i started getting into the condo
conversion business we converted about
20
000 condos throughout florida and vegas
and arizona
from 2003 to 2008 we did very very well
uh we were doing like 500 closings a
month it was crazy and what do you do
when you convert them
do you buy a uh it's like you buy a
rental building a garden apartment or a
high rise we did right here at the view
at prickle
the view of prickle right over here it's
right around the corner we
we uh put that high rise we converted
like 355 units there
we do is you buy a rental building you
basically put some little paint down
paint the walls a little bit in the
garden apartments you paint the parking
space a little uh
white stripes you put two banks in each
room and just put them for sale
got it so you basically buy the building
you spruce them up and then you can use
it
and then you convert them into condos
you gotta go to condo docks you take the
rentals convert them into condos
and now you're selling apartments as
condos
and it was very hot market you know
three to oh eight and we did
we'd like 20 000 units wow and then the
money we made from that
i took and i started buying land in
downtown miami
and downtown miami for those that don't
know uh when they think of downtown they
probably think of south beach but south
beach is not downtown no no south beach
is not downtown at all
south beaches by where the ocean is
there's a bridge that connects miami
beach to miami
miami when you hear about miami now
you're exploding you're primarily
and predominantly speaking about
downtown miami
you know downtown miami used to not even
have any um cultures or any
distinctions fast forward to today you
have
you know the park west area which 11 is
in which is going to be the
hottest booming area where all the big
high-rises are being built
where the train station is the grand
central station it takes you to
west palm beach for laura del now
there's stations being built in aventura
and boca
orlando will be opening up next year
then there's going to go to jacksonville
uh in tampa so that's the grand central
stage by right in that neighborhood you
also have the american alliance arena
which is now the ftx arena
you know the crypto uh coming to
dominate the marketplace
you have the museum of art and science
you have the performing arts center
you have the people mover yeah you have
the new on off ramps the two billion
dollar project to build uh
the extend the highway so everything all
the infrastructure is going to that area
and this that's going to be the main
area like the times square area with all
the action is
in miami at the end of the day then from
there you have the tentacles you have
the windwood
you have the midtown you have the design
district then
those are all to the north then to the
south you have the cbd district central
business district
which is right before break the brickell
then you have brickell which has
always been booming because that was the
first area really built up with the
financial markets
and condos because the area of park west
where 11 is
people used to come down and big tractor
trailers
to come down to go to the cargo port you
have to come off the exit go to sixth
street and go onto the cargo port
which is like the third biggest cargo
port in the country and those trucks for
the reason that area was never developed
before
but there was a tunnel built about four
years ago that alleviates all that
traffic
and now it's opening up that area to be
the area where there's
all the new construction is and that's
why you see all this infrastructure
there and that's where a lot of the real
estate you own is that's where all the
real estate that we are this we own uh
at one time another i owned um maybe
like 30 40 acres we sold some off we
we arbitraged some we stayed in some and
today my partner
primaries michael simpkins romy chara
and brent cylinders
and iris sapperstein you know michael
and i own
most of it and then we have a few other
partners in other
uh smaller pieces but we own about 12
acres okay
enough to build maybe like 20 high-rises
all right and so
as you do this uh at what point do you
say i want to get into the club business
because i think that this story is
fascinating in terms of as you're buying
up the land i don't think
the club business was necessarily uh
something not business was never
never in my mindset there was a club in
the middle of the whole assemblage
because i did all the acquisitions for
miami world center
uh i was a co-founder of that with art
falcone
and then in 2012 i started assembling
the rest of the
area which is uh contiguous to my world
center but right off the highway
with michael simpkins and his family um
and i was going down the street one day
with uh one of my friends
and he points to the club there was a
strip club there called gold rush
we renamed a club that we have up on
77th and biscayne gold rush but this was
gold rush this was
the original the original gold rush it's
92. this was an outright down and dirty
dingy gum on the floor
yeah you wouldn't even walk in kind of
place you know you'd have to shower for
a week after the other
so but it was open 24 hours
and my friend says what's with that it's
the only thing i don't know in the
neighborhood i said ah i've never
sell it's it's 24 hours is
guys just never selling so that night i
want to go you know who says a guy will
never sell let me go see if this guy
will ever sell that place because i just
went
for the real estate yep i didn't realize
i really didn't realize what was coming
down the pike so i did my thing i always
buy
everything i always bought the
neighborhood with what was called a
beard
i don't go in myself because they see my
name they started hearing bells whistles
and
they hit the lottery so i always get a a
beard another person
to go in and and buy something so i
called up a buddy of mine and said
you're gonna be my beard go in call the
cfo the company see what the story is
just happened to catch
when the owner of the place was uh he
was in a hospital
and he was ill and it wasn't good it was
looking good for him for the future
let's just put it that way um so i
we did what we do best we penetrated
them we uh
you know got them to the table and i got
them under contract
i got them on a contract for you know a
steal of a price for me because i was
looking at real estate
other people in the club business um it
turns out this guy was like an icon he
had 90
strip clubs this guy wow and everything
the kingpin
of strip club is in south florida yeah
this guy this guy's the kind of guy at
so many
clubs he would say the manager listen
give me an envelope this much a week
you keep the rest wow this is going back
to old school
like the 70s the 80s the 90s this guy
was really old school
so i ended up getting a contract the
minute the word got out that i had
another contract
every strip club operator in the country
you know you name them you know
you know from from scores to hustler
to sapphire you name it they came to see
me and at that time my partner michael
simkins we
said you know what let's just meet
everybody and see what they have in mind
and why did they want to come see you
guys they want to help you operate it or
they want to buy it
well firstly they want to know is how
the heck did you get this on a contract
he promised me he would sell it to me
he was promising everybody in the
business oh i'm when i sell you're the
one that's getting it
meanwhile this this guy obviously didn't
want to sell anybody in the street club
business competitors
he he was never selling to these guys so
they all came in and they all
gave us huge presentations and why they
should be the ones to be our partner on
it they all said listen we'll give you
five million dollars we'll give you a
hundred grand a month in rent and we'll
be 50 50 partners
that was everybody's wrap so my partner
michael simpkins and i we're looking
each other going
man this these people came fast they
didn't just come back over a period of a
month they came within a week we met
everybody in the whole industry they
came fast and furious it was like you
were the prettiest girl at the prom
it was unbelievable so we said you know
what why don't we go try to put together
a management team ourself
see we do this ourselves we need these
guys we can find the right team
so we met it started interviewing other
people who's gonna match us michael and
i we don't manage
clubs we don't run clubs it's uh you
know it's a real art what do you
it's a different business it's a
different business and we just wanted a
club we had nothing to do with
it all we have nothing in mind and we'd
want any kind of club like that even our
neighborhood
he wanted to do something classy and
what and
eventually what eleven became so we met
dennis degory
and dennis tagore really seemed like a
really smart guy
and he had a great reputation and we
made a deal with dennis that he would
operate the club
and put the team together and
then we started forming a concept and
you know
a lot of people came up with a concept
they want to do this so under that
dennis had a
real clear real clear vision michael and
i had as well
and agreed with on turning it into what
eleven is today a very very high-end
nightclub
with a very small component of you have
beautiful girls
because eleven is anything but us we
don't even use that word
not any of our staff ever use that word
you know it's just
get a lot of demerits you know it's what
11
is is a unique nightlife experience
and what we did was we tore down the
building the gold rush was in
and we built the close to a 40 million
facility it would put a tremendous
amount of money we put in
the best of everything the best sound
system the best boots the best design
i mean dennis was working on this design
and uh with the architects
uh uh for like maybe i don't know three
four months and we built it in nine
months
world record time we built the club i
mean literally world record time
and it was very challenging at first
every thought we were nuts
how are you ever gonna make that money
back how are you doing
like what are you doing and at the
beginning
these other guys because you did have to
have a a beautiful girl component
the girls every everybody that was these
girls working elsewhere
they were telling them clubs all
throughout florida if you go work at 11
you're never going to work at this club
again and you're never going to work at
any club again
so we said oh man you know these girls
are unknown they don't want they were
doing
fine so we had to go hire girls from all
over the world and fly them in
and we had to pay for their travel pay
for their meals pay from the work
it was spending a lot of money each week
the first three four months was kind of
challenging
so we'd just start out like a big bang
then we started getting traction
and we put on shows the cirque du soleil
shows our service is amazing
and we started people pew star realized
it's a very unique experience
and lo and behold it started getting
busier and busier and busier and busier
and towards the end of the first year we
said we're onto something
and then all the girls started coming
because the word was out well the heavy
hitters were coming there money was
being made
with social media today it doesn't take
long for a word to get out when these
girls start making money
and now fast forward today and we're the
number one club in the world we're at a
number one club in almost every category
your number one club selling uh for our
tequila or vodka or eleven fock is
unbelievable
what's up guys bang bang i hope you're
enjoying this conversation but before we
go any further i want to quickly tell
you about today's sponsor
block five block five's got four
different financial products for crypto
investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
again blockfy.com pomp go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it where
did the brand come from so
you have the 11 hat on it's very unique
in terms of for those who can't see it
uh it's basically the word 11 spelled
but uh
rather than one l there's basically two
l's or
or the number 11. right so it's e 11 and
then
e v e n where did that brand come from
well 11 is on 11th street so we named it
11.
uh and the hats were a natural he's got
hats
we we put together the hats and next
thing you know everybody and their
mother wanted to wear a hat
we sell seven figures of these hats a
year
really yeah seven figures and and is the
uh the double l or the the number 11 in
the name
where that was just like uh yeah yeah we
have a big marketing team
and uh as a collaboration of uh our
marketing team dennis tagore
tina lopinto daniel solomon they they
all got together and you know michael
and i
loved it and we just ran with it and it
became iconic i mean you see these hats
everywhere
when i go out of the country i see my
west coast i see them they're all over
new york
everywhere in miami and like i said we
sell seven figures a year
in hats and which is pretty incredible
because most people give hats away
for name recognition you sell these hats
for 50 a hat
and then we have another hat that lights
up and we sell out for a hundred dollars
a hat
and we can't keep them in stock mark
roberts the hat salesman of the year
you try well what's fascinating about
the brand is obviously you've built this
club right it
is uh incredible from financial
performance standpoint it's literally
the highest grossing
club in the world per square foot uh and
as
you just described the story it was a
real estate uh kind of play and you were
really focusing real estate and then you
guys kind of backed into
uh the club business you guys now have
two clubs right between 11 and gold rush
yeah well uh gold rush is more of a
protective measure because okay there's
only two licenses
uh to um in downtown miami
so we're kind of protecting ourselves by
we want to own both
uh we like monopolies and
gold rush has really taken off because
it's an alternative it's not didn't like
11 at all
but people love gold rush they love
going there they have a great time there
it's a different vibe so it's a
complimentary because you can't go to
eleven every night even though some
people do
so i mean both places not gonna be doing
fantastic
but eleven is the catalyst is eleven
open 24 7.
24 7. it never closed that's unique
right well i'll show you nick
[Laughter]
so how does that operate if you're open
24 7. you just have staff that kind of
comes through
all the time we have staff uh three
shifts a day yeah and they just
they rotate yeah they rotated we have uh
yep
a lot of days between what's good about
it is it's open
but it gives us a lot of time to clean
up the place looks spotless every day we
keep it spotless
so we you know we keep all those workers
working and whatever it keeps everybody
happy
yeah and so the 11 brand now you guys
are branching out and you've got 11
residences
uh so maybe describe like the residence
tower and kind of what you guys are
doing there
well the 11 hotel and residences is our
big goal
especially this year is to expand our ip
and we were very cognizant of what
happened with playboy playboy went out
in february at a 400 million dollar
market cap
today it sits at a two billion dollar
market cap
i can't even find a play but i don't
even i don't anybody even reads a
playboy
but they took the name and they were
unbelievably successful at taking the ip
and creating different verticals with it
so uh
we looked at it and we said you know
what we could build a multi-billion
dollar business off of our ip
uh 11 is the catalyst the club i mean
every
i mean there's not anybody who comes to
town doesn't go there everybody wants to
go there
there's 500 to a thousand people tonight
trying to get in and clone their way in
so we said how do you take advantage of
that so the first thing we thought of is
you know of course the hats and then we
started our own vodka
which uh you know nikki simkins who's my
partner michael's wife is the ceo
we've done a really good job and nick
has an amazing job of getting it all
over florida
our strategy with the vodka is let's
dominate florida first
put it everywhere we can saturate
florida
obviously the only vodka we serve at the
club which
alone is a huge business and then we'll
take a national and we've came out you
know less than a year ago
and we're in uh almost a thousand places
now
it's doing amazing uh southern wine
spirits who distributes it is
uh you know on board to you know help us
expand because they see how successful
it is
so check that box and that's 11 vodka
11. and we won the double gold award at
the san francisco tasting contest about
two three months ago
which is the leading uh uh award that
you could get in the field like every
spirit
strives to be a double gold award and we
want it which is incredible
because it tastes so great and everybody
loves it the taste and by the way it's
made
here in miami it's local and we've got
some great local support from everybody
and it's look at us so you know i
support everything local and everybody
here has been phenomenal supporting it
and branching out into other counties
so now we have the vodka so then we said
okay
how we can make this more iconic the ip
so last year we
we went and we said let's build an 11
hotel and residences but it's got to be
iconic it's got to be
the best of the best because 11 stands
for the best you know if you're going 11
you're going to get an amazing
experience you're going to get the best
of the best you're going to happy live
your life be happy
with your life everybody around it's
going to be you know people that
are ambitious and happy and positive
attitude
and that's really what the brand stands
for it's going to create an environment
like that
in a building so we partnered you know
i'm a very good land assembler and we're
we're great real estate guys in a lot of
respects but we don't build high-rise
it's very difficult tasks so we said
who's the best high-rise builder
and pmg property management group is
built of like
probably a hundred high rises very
successful
so we teamed up with them and uh their
two lead partners are kevin maloney and
ryan scheer
and ryan lives here in miami and we got
to get to know him real well
and we started uh figuring there's a lot
of synergies
and we trusted him and he's great hard
worker or
he's got the culture we were looking for
so we partnered up with them
and we started designing the tower and
we came out with it i don't know i guess
sort of like when covered was ending and
we sold it out in less than a month
and that's the residence in terms of uh
people can come in and they can actually
buy the uh
the resident yeah people come in they
buy a resident
and they have the option you can either
uh rent it out when you're not there or
just keep it into your residence you
don't have to rent it out
and it went over so big and i sold
probably half the units myself
the people i know uh i mean literally
yep and we not only sold it out
fast we sold it out without a sales
office not a sales office built yet
and we sold out the club wasn't even
open the club was closed the miller
covert
it's crazy so it's really crazy it's a
world record we set
like pmg never sold anything out that
fast nobody's ever seen anything sell
out that fast
and the clientele we sold it to our mega
names that we
we're getting ready to announce some of
them they're kind of mind-boggling names
just
a lot of uh you know the kind of people
that everybody wants to associate
themselves with be around
and it's what we're going to create is
at a las vegas
type of hotel with those kinds of
amenities without the casino
in a five-star uh environment
so we're gonna have the best of the best
restaurants the best of the best sports
bar
the best of the best gym the best the
best med spa the best
best you know deepak chopra has been
announced the wellness center
you know deep rock lending his name to
us is you know a good milestone for us
because
you know it's another vertical that you
know wants to collaborate with us
you know we have music studios
it's going to be the place where
everybody's going to want to be
and our pool party is to be second to
none nobody's ever going to see a pool
party like this
ever that they're going to see at 11
hotel residences what
what is the like average price of a unit
there right so just so people get a
sense for it well the average square
foot price is eleven hundred and fifty
dollars a square foot
i'd say the average price is hovers
around a million
bucks you know we sold one unit for 22
million dollars which broke all the
records
in downtown miami that's me my next uh
comment was the unit that sold for 22
million somebody paid in
bitcoin or crypto yes they're crypto
uh guys a lot of crypto people have
bought in the crypto community which
even made me more enthusiastic about the
crypto because you started taking it at
the club
and then you announced that you were
going to accept it for purchase of the
residents
and p and i think again people were like
ah they did the club thing like maybe
that's just kind of a stunt
oh now they're doing it at the resident
no one's gonna buy one and then
literally you broke the record for a
condo sale
in downtown miami for 22 million dollars
uh so i bought it with uh i don't know
if it was bitcoin or something else
well well here's here's the way it's
gonna work the first 10 deposits we not
announced yet that we were taking
uh crypto crypto wasn't even like really
on our radar screen we took the first
10. it was a little bit on it but then
when all the momentum started building
and the conference came and
i started becoming so gung-ho on it and
become such a believer
the second deposits that would take uh
were accepting
uh crypto we've got indications from the
guys they're the crypto business they're
buying of course they're going to pay a
crypto
so we're expecting maybe a 10 to 15
of uh the second deposits in bitcoin
because we take bitcoin people we
convert it there's other coins and
somehow my guy's converting the bitcoin
but i like bitcoin so basically
everything
you take everything but you put it in
bitcoin and the goal is to not sell it
into cash you hold it as bitcoin
uh i'm a big believer in bitcoin
but this is why we are friends i'm a
very big believer in bitcoin
all right and so as you're doing this
what's
next for the 11 brand right so you've
got the club you've got the vodka you've
got the residence
and hotel are you going to look for more
opportunities to leverage the brand and
kind of do iconic
things and build off the ip uh yes
there's some things in the crypto field
very exciting things that i really don't
want to announce
every single copy of these days so i do
it i'm not going to be
trying to copy us i'll tell you offline
of course
you're my crypto guru of course um so
there's some exciting things we're doing
with that universe
that we're really excited about uh we're
also um building
a right now a real infrastructure that
we're
uh we've interviewed a lot of top
quality people to be our ceo of our
intellectual property division we've all
interviewed a lot of people to be
second in command and so for insurance
we're very determined
to build a a really big crypto
infrastructure
between our ip you know that we could
handle the crypto we could handle
for instance like we want to do a
cannabis perhaps you want to do
um you know a lingerie we want to do
sunglass line
we want we want to do anything that
anybody will license
we really want to be in the licensing
business because that's where the money
is
you license our name we'll oversee it
and we'll help market it and push it
but let's say we want to hook up with
the top sunglasses manufacturing up the
top lingerie manufacturer
i'm gonna hook up with the you know
maybe uh you know the top cannabis uh
uh brand out there um and we've certain
brands we're talking to right now
and at the end of the day we wanna
really i wanna say emulate like maybe
what a uh
playboy did but we want to uh create a
licensing platform that we can monetize
because those are the best because when
you're sleeping they're making you money
yeah well and also part of it is once
you build the brand
the commoditization of the goods uh to
some degree works in your favor because
you can take your brand
match it with the commoditized good and
now all of a sudden you can
uh create something that people want uh
and really differentiate yourself from
the competitors in that market
yeah well i don't think anybody has the
brand recognition we have right now
um we've done studies and a lot we our
brand is super
super strong uh it's well recognized
the uh demographics that it's recognized
with the exact demographic that
advertisers go after
you know i mean listen how many
democrats you have where you could go
from
i mean teenage kids aspire uh to go to
eleven for their 21st birthday
and that's like what they that's like
when i was young age look forward to
when i could drive when i was 18.
like literally all anywhere i go with
young kids they're in their teens fifth
they go yo my son and all he wants to do
is go there so it's all he talks about
so we have that capture that audience
then of course you have the 21
to 25 to 30 year olds we capture that
audience
30 to 40 we capture that orders we go
right up to 70.
we have 80 year olds come in and have a
great time we have more
women than men on a lot of nights really
oh more women than men a fact
we do more bachelorette parties than
bachelor parties that's a fact
wow that's why the brand is so unique
and so strong
because most people would associate men
going there bachelor parties that type
of stuff
but actually it's more female and more
like bachelorette parties i'd say
if you really had to go throughout the
year it's maybe 55 45 which is
astounding
yep but that's just another example it
has nothing to do with a strip club
nothing to do with it it has everything
to do with the unique nightlife
experience you know you see the cirque
du lay shows they cost us
millions and millions of dollars a year
to put on we spend real money
going putting back energy yeah and we we
bring in top djs
and we bring in top acts like we gave
drake did his first major performance
uh there a few years ago we'd usher this
is early on now we have everybody there
everybody comes through and plays in
reality on those nights we make less
money
because we have to pay them yeah but we
do it because we want to give the
customers and our clients
the best experience and they go home and
talk about it and so on and so forth
you know we we literally were building a
brand
we just didn't know how powerful until
we started look at each other okay we
really got something here
lightning in a bottle and in the next uh
this year you're gonna see us lay in
infrastructure and i think we'll see
uh 11 getting licensed in a lot of uh
areas with a lot of credibility to it
you're an ip uh company that's licensing
a great brand
and what i think i appreciate the most
about you is you want to be first and
you want to be iconic
and being first in everything from
accepting bitcoin to
you know other things that you guys do
uh and then the iconic experience of the
nightclub the iconic hotel in residence
right like
you keep using the same language over
and over again but that's what makes you
guys stand out that's what gives the
brand kind of the legs that it stands on
well you know if you go back you know my
career i only had one
goal when i left college i never wanted
to have a boss
my only goal i said i could go through
my life without a boss i did pretty good
so i was the first one uh to promote a
professional boxing match at 19. i was
the first one to take a sports
management company public
before i was 30. and then when i got
down here
you know everybody said nobody's ever
bought all this so many pre-construction
so i put down a little bit of first
bracket then we started doing condo
conversions
we we were among the first they really
got into that
and and then when we then of course you
know it's the first one to start
assembling land prime land in downtown
miami it's going to be the best
land in downtown miami at the end of the
day by co-founding miami world center
and by having the acreage we have left
with my partners
and then of course the club you know i
think was a manifestation
of all that and putting everything first
mover into that and you know my
uh main partner michael simkins and
dennis degory
we all are very aligned in what we do
you know it's kind of like you always
have to have
i've had bad partners and on this one i
got very lucky i have great partners
and we're all aligned in what we're
doing and building and we
first move in everything we do because
we do quick when everybody's aligned
things could
work very quickly you know these big
corporations
uh it takes between the red tape that's
why
it could take them forever that's why
entrepreneurs will always win the day
so we like to fancy ourselves as you
know entrepreneurs
fast movers and you know we're well
financed and we can move quickly and
that's like they're going to win the day
i tend to think you're doing a great job
all right uh i asked everyone three
questions before we end and then you get
asked me one question to finish up
the first question is what's the most
important book you think you've ever
read
robert trules i knew you were going to
say that
all right what's robert's rules that's a
book i wrote back in 1998
uh it's a story behind that one too you
know i
my buddy roger king who uh king world
productions he owned the oprah winfrey
show
and i used to hang out with roger a lot
and i came out my book
and my book is more of like rules like
my philosophies my business philosophies
uh teachings and i had a huge publicity
campaign going like a half million
dollar publicity
campaign in place by my publisher
i had the oprah winfrey show back then
if you won the oprah winfrey show
game you were guaranteed to be a number
one seller roger king only oprah winfrey
show
he had me set up there i was going to be
the i wasn't not going to be the book of
the day i was going to book it a month
i made the whole thing lined up for me i
was in the front of
barnes and noble front of borders this
whole thing was teed up like you
wouldn't believe
um as you very well know well the
audience may not know this but when you
take a company public and have a public
company
before you do a financing okay there's
something called a quiet period
you're not allowed to talk about your
company at all you're not allowed to
promote it and just as luck would have
it
because i did all these deals a year and
a half before my book come down you have
to set all this up you don't just want
to snap your fingers
the luck would have it i was doing a
secondary offering simultaneously with
my book launch
so you know i go on uh
my book came out i go on giants against
the green bay packers on a sunday
afternoon
at 12 o'clock i got interviewed right
before the game by donna hanover
giuliani rudy julian's wife at the time
she started asking me about my book so
of course i got to talk about the
company i started
sorry about the company worldwide
entertainment i started talking about
this and that
you know i just said enough two minutes
go by it was a two minute quick thing
the next day it was monday my sec
lawyers got a call from the sec
listen we see roberts on tv on radio if
we would see him anywhere near
the airwaves we were holding your
secondary offering for six months
minimum
meanwhile i had a 25 million dollars
singing their offering coming like the
money was like ready to go
a guy that called me up so you can't go
on the air that's what's going on for
winfrey that week
okay so i was like oh man it's like one
of the worst calls i ever had
so i'm like oh 25 million oprah winfrey
and this is going back yo yeah coming
back a while back now this going back
like 22 years
obviously 25 million went out so i
called my publisher i said listen i got
very bad news for you
this guy put a half like this guy was
like ready to go you know this guy does
300 books a year i was number one book
obviously of the year this guy threw his
we were
hitting gold i said you understand i
can't believe this happened
i can't go on oprah i i never got cursed
out like this in my life this guy cursed
me for three minutes straight i
deserved i just took it and he goes you
call up i'm done and he hung the phone i
never talked to the guy since by the way
really i never told the guy since this
guy was so mad at me i'd call it the
executive producer of oprah winfrey show
i start talking to her and she starts
going ha you're funny mr roberts you're
funny you're funny
she's like kidding around because i
thought i can't go on the show you know
i don't talk about quiet periods
yeah yeah yeah so low and behold i
finally got this check can't go out she
told him like the stupidest human ping
she ever met
hung the phone up and i never went over
once
borders pulled it off they were putting
on sites going on oprah they were
getting ready for the avalanche
so uh that was very bad for the book but
lo and behold the book did well
didn't do great like it should have
would have done but i think a lot of i
got a lot of letters
back then there was no emails a lot of
letters and loads of letters thousands
of letters out change people's lives and
everyone that reads it i think learned
something from it and it was a great
experience and
then and he's got a picture of you on
the front yeah yeah
and i did that back then it's funny how
that works i love it
all right second question is sleep
schedule
you and i will text at all hours of the
day it could be
6 a.m noon 8 p.m 2 a.m
you're always on what is your sleep
schedule well here's
that's that's what happened i was about
16 17 years old
you know this this was the day that
changed my life okay i had a
big thing going on the night it was like
a saturday night a big thing going on at
night
but i fell asleep i played a lot i
played a lot of basketball i was a kid
like eight hours a day
i had a big basketball day i went home
for somebody i just fell asleep
so i woke up i thought it was the
morning i thought i missed everything i
was panicking i kept like missed this
particular
wow and i look at the clock i only slept
three hours
okay you don't ever do that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you feel like it's in the
morning you know you don't know
where you're at so i i got in the shower
took a shower and i was just fresh as a
daisy
so i started saying to myself you know
why don't i try doing this all the time
i'll be saving a lot of you know i'm
gonna live a lot many years
so i started teaching myself how to get
up so i started doing it three hours
three or three hours
so to this day i only sleep like three
hours a night
so i believe my my motto is you'll sleep
when you die
you do realize that that is insane
well people say that but you know it's i
mean i i
very rarely have gotten sick i very
uh really are slowly down and
i like to think it's been a big
advantage for me because when other
people are sleeping i've been working
and literally i know you are because i
think
uh this morning you text me at like
three a.m
right so like you literally you live
this i know you do
uh third question is aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
i find hard to believe there's aliens
you think no but i think that's
hard but you know what i found it hard
to believe a lot of things in life
i find a lot of things hard to believe
these days i never thought i'd see covid
i never think i
think i'd ever see what we've been
through i have i've
never thought i'd see uh the uh uh
society where you want to defund police
you know i there's so much i've believed
in my lifetime i never see but the older
you get the
you you realize you see the more you see
so you really can come down like i used
to say
during covet and i used to see some of
the policies people have with taxes and
what they want to do to the economy and
so these policy makers
i used to say you know i would if aliens
came onto the beach of
miami beach and started walking up the
beach it wouldn't shock me anymore
i really used to i really was saying
animals
the world was getting really crazy i got
ufos now yeah so
am i a believer i find harder to believe
but nothing shocks me anymore
i think that is a great way to uh look
at life is to be
uh skeptical yet understand that the
world is a wild place and anything can
happen
yes all right you could ask me one
question and finish up what do you got
for me yeah where is bitcoin gonna be
a year to 18 months from now oh i have
no clue
um higher than it is today
that's the best answer i have for you
over really really long periods of time
for sure
there's lots of short-term price
volatility right so you get uh
it goes up it goes down it goes sideways
it goes up it goes down it goes out i
mean just over and over and over and
over again
but i think when you look the longer the
timeline the easier it is to say
it's going to go up because of the
structure of it that the kind of market
structure
but i think that we've got a quite a bit
of room to run for this year and then
we'll see what happens kind of going
into next year and uh
does it kind of go back into a bear
market for a little bit or
uh does it kind of level off nobody
really knows yeah one more question for
you all right
where will you be at age 40 at age 40
hopefully doing this with you again i
love it
great answer all right where should we
send people
on the internet should we send them to
something about 11 something about you
where you want to send them well you
know my website's markroberts.com
all right there's a great video on there
i think people enjoy all right
marc roberts.com yes i really enjoy that
very much says a lot of stuff about 11
and where we're going it's getting
updated all the time
but i think everybody uh that uh could
afford it
it'd be very wise to buy in the 11 hotel
residences
that were sold out of this one but you
know we're
we're going to be uh hopefully uh in the
future having a lot of opportunity for
people to jump on the 11 bandwagon
and embrace the ip live it and uh we
look forward to seeing at the club very
soon
i'm a believer keep going i will do this
again in the future
thanks look forward to it